[Music]
you unlock this door with the key of
imagination this is an object a
collection of properties where each
property associate say key to a value
earlier in the course we learned that
there are seven primitive data types in
Java Script primitives represent a
single value like a number or a string
and anything that's not a primitive is
an object in other words everything
interesting that happens in JavaScript
is made possible by the object datatype
today we'll take a deep dive into how
the JavaScript object works and look at
modern syntax and methods we can use to
make our code cleaner and more efficient
if you're new here like and subscribe
and grab all of the videos on this free
JavaScript course from bioship io an
object is conceptually similar to a
dictionary or a map that you might find
in other programming languages the most
straightforward way to create an object
is to use the literal syntax simply
define a variable equal to curly braces
inside the braces you define properties
separated by commas a property is
essentially a key value pair where the
left side is the property name and the
right side is the property value the
property name needs to be a unique value
that can be coerced to a string the
value can be anything you want a
primitive another object a function or
whatever now even though we define this
object as a const variable we can still
set properties on it after it's been
created we can use bracket notation on
the object followed by the name of the
property equal to whatever value we want
to set there then later in the code we
can read or get that property using the
same bracket notation
now let's imagine that we've walked into
an alternate universe because in
JavaScript there is always more than one
way to do things
this time we'll create a new object
using the constructor syntax then we'll
set properties on it using dot notation
dot notation looks a lot cleaner but
your property names will need to be a
continuous string that does not start
with a number if you have property names
with spaces or that start with numbers
you'll get a syntax error if you try to
call them with dot notation but now
we've fallen into yet another alternate
universe this time we'll use a static
method on the object class called create
you wouldn't normally use this one for
an empty object it's most useful when
you have an existing object and you want
it to inherit its properties or in other
words use the existing object as a
prototype and this is one of the weirder
parts of JavaScript so let's look at it
a little more closely first we have a
plain JavaScript object called organism
it contains a DNA property of a random
number and we create a new object with
object create passing the organism as
the prototype when we console.log the
new object you'll notice that it's still
a blank object but if we call the DNA
property on this object we get a result
back so it's almost like an invisible
property on the new object that's
because it exists on this objects
prototype and we can see this property
actually lives on the prototype by
calling object get prototype of which
returns the original object we created
[Music]
[Music]
we're going to add a property to the
object by using object defined property
it takes the object as its first
argument the name of the key as the
second argument then an object with some
options on it known as a descriptor as
the third argument we can use the value
option in the descriptor to create an
object that is identical to the ones in
the previous examples however we can now
do more advanced things here as well
like to find a getter and that would
access the property by calling a
function now most casual users of
JavaScript won't need to use defined
property on a regular basis but it is
important to know how it works if you
really want to understand the language
in most cases you'll likely be working
with the literal syntax and it does have
a few cool tricks up its sleeve let's
say we have a couple of variables and we
want to set those variables on an object
with the same property names as the
variable in the olden days we would have
to duplicate the property name with the
variable but in modern times we can
simply add the variable to the object
literal and it will coerce the variable
name to the property name and we can do
a similar thing in Reverse with
destructuring this time we want to read
an object's properties and set them as
variables to use in our local code in
the olden days we would have to declare
a variable and then set its value equal
to the object property nowadays we can
define multiple variables with a single
line of code and JavaScript will match
the variable names to the property names
on the object but what if you want to
use this awesome syntax but give your
variable a different name sometimes you
might have to do this to avoid a name
collision with an existing variable just
add a colon after the property name and
then you can name your D structured
variable whatever you want now what if
your to try to take this code and then
add another property with the same name
this code won't throw an error instead
it will overwrite the value on the left
with the value on the right this is
important to know because sometimes you
might compute properties that you don't
know until run time like you might want
to create an object based on some data
you fetch from a database you can
compute property names by wrapping them
in brackets and then place an expression
inside and it will compute that value
when the object is created in this
example we have a function that
generates a random number we can then
call that function inside of the
brackets to generate the key for this
object when the object is created and
you'll notice every time we refresh we
get a different key or a name for this
property now object properties can also
take functions as their value and when a
function lives on an object it's called
a method you can define a method using
the shorthand syntax where you omit the
property name and just define a named
function directly in the object literal
and we can also use get and set keywords
here to define getters and setters on
this object when you define a method on
an object this refers to this object
however if you remember from the last
video if you use the arrow function
syntax here it will refer to the global
this context for example if we convert
our make web method into an arrow
function this dot web will refer to the
global web value as opposed to the
internal property on this object so
that's just a weird little thing to get
used to in JavaScript an interesting
thing you can do with the this keyword
is chain methods together you'll see the
syntax used in different JavaScript
libraries with the most famous example
being jQuery so the question is how do
we chained together methods while
keeping a reference to the same object I
kind of already gave you the answer
because remember I said the this keyword
refers to the parent object when defined
in name
so if you want to chain method calls
together all you have to do is return
this from the method now any method you
call will return the reference to the
original object and that provides a good
segue into the topic of object
references previously in the course we
learned the difference between the call
stack and the heap primitive values are
short-lived in most cases in the call
stack while javascript objects are kept
as references in the heap let's take a
second to look at the implications of
this because it's very important let's
look at how things work first with
primitives we'll initialize a variable a
and then set B equal to a as you would
expect they're both the same value but
they're actually both pointing to their
own primitive value so that means if we
change a to a different value
console.log them again you can see a has
the new value but B still has the
original value that it got from a now
let's go ahead and refactor things to
make a and object the big difference
here is that B is making a reference to
the object created in a they are both
referencing the same object kept in the
heap memory as opposed to copying the
value like it did with a primitive after
we update the property you can see that
they both console.log the same object
because again they're both sharing the
same reference to it now that you know
how it references work let's take a look
at how we can combine objects together
if you're updating the same object in
multiple places it can be kind of
difficult because of the weight
references work in many cases you simply
want to clone that object's property
into a new object and one way to achieve
that is with object to sign let's see
how it can change the behavior of our
previous example instead of setting B
equal to a we use object to sign to take
a brand new object and assign A's
properties to it now it's important to
keep in mind that this only uses the
internal and numerable properties of a
you can see exactly which properties
will be copied over by using object get
own property names and that will give
you an array of all the property names
owned directly by this object that means
any other properties that had inherited
higher up in the prototype chain would
not be copied over in addition if this
object were to reference other objects
in its properties those objects would
not be recursively deep copied over as
well that means if a was making a
reference to other objects those objects
would still be copied over by reference
it wouldn't recursively copy all the
values in those nested objects
I'm not sure at all if you're looking to
clone objects like this a better
alternative might be to use these spread
syntax there are some very minor
differences between the two but they can
be used interchangeably in most cases
and the spread syntax just looks a lot
nicer when you're combining a lot of
objects together now at the very
beginning of the video I defined an
object as a collection of key-value
pairs and when you have a collection of
something you likely want to loop over
it looping over an array is easy
but how do we loop over an object well
one option is to use a four in loop this
will loop over all of the enumerable
properties in the object as well as its
prototypes and this can be very very
confusing so most people tend to avoid
the for in loop a better alternative is
to get the keys or values as an array
you can use object keys or values to do
exactly that then you can loop over them
with a regular for loop or you can use
one of the built-in array methods like
for each but what if you want to loop
over both the keys and the values
together you can get an array of tuples
using object entries and you can D
structure that key and value variables
in the loop now I showed you earlier how
to create a new object using the new
keyword but what if you want to
customize the way that object is created
you can do that easily in JavaScript by
writing a constructor function by
convention you should always capitalize
the name of this function in this case
we have a zombie function and it takes
an argument of name we'll take that
argument and define it as an internal
property on the object and then we can
handle additional setup in this function
like setting a timestamp and also
defining some methods you'll notice that
it's the this keyword that allows us to
reference internal properties on this
object when it's created or instantiated
so this function is actually very
similar to a class like you might find
in other object-oriented programming
languages when you define a constructor
function like this the way you
initialize a new object is to put the
new keyword in front of it now in modern
JavaScript we could actually skip the
function and just use the class keyword
but the important takeaway here is that
we're using a function to instantiate or
create a new object the class keyword is
mostly just syntactic sugar for this
process as you can see javascript
objects are very flexible and a core
building block up a language I'm going
to go ahead and wrap things up there if
this video helped you please like and
subscribe and make sure
to check out the full JavaScript
Khorasan buyer ship IO thanks for
watching and I will talk to you soon
beauty is in the eye of beholder
[Music]